(music)
(birds chirping)
(rooster crows)
- Please, Lord,
make me the biggest star
the world has ever known
so that I make it far,
far away from this place.
- Now, caring for your family
during these times is admirable,
but you only get one
take at this life.
- If only they would just die.
- Pardon?
- Nothing.
(boards creaking)
- [woman, calling]
Peter!
(alligator growling)
- I wanna be special,
dancing up on the screen
like the pretty
girls in the pictures.
- I will not let you
leave this farm again.
I'm worried there may be
something real wrong with me.
- Rumor has it
they only take one gal in town.
- [woman] Next.
- [man] We are looking for
someone with X factor.
- Has to be me.
- How about a film
nobody else has seen?
- Is it legal?
- Will be eventually.
- I know what I've done.
Bad things.
Terrible, awful,
murderous things.
- Help me!
- I want to be loved from
as many people as possible...
but truth is I'm not
really a good person.
(screaming)